hey itty get to know us it's a
[Music]
nice
we are so super exciting and at the same
time a little bit nervous yeah
everything I guess but especially we
have our special stage we have our first
English single boys like you and it's
our first time actually performing it on
stage and it's like
well I wouldn't say only but it's our
first time uh showing it to our fans at
our US tour so that's one of the special
parts
like this yeah yeah and also like a
special ritual we have this
which means like itsy bitsy let's fly
high yeah it's like a special ritual to
kind of like cheer us up
[Music]
first of all when our music is like a
top of the chart we really feel thankful
for our fans and also to the people who
work with us because because of their
hard works we could
be able to release the album great album
and great songs so yeah I think that's
the biggest feeling that I feel
[Music]
out of control
energy
confidence energy
anger Crush
[Music]
I think it's Yeti
I think
and also is oh yeah yeah I think two two
of them
[Music]
one two three
legs
always wake up in the morning and
Leah's I I go to Leah's room Leah wake
up wake up wake up yes it's her mom more
morning routine
yes
in the morning for me
uh recently free fall in the morning
that's really good to perform me be in
love I can't choose but
yes
in the morning
[Music]
oh my good shoes I can't choose but um
my favorite is chocolate and candy and
snacks um
and potato chip my favorite yes snacks
uh fruits uh with with honey yeah
and I like drinks I I think yeah I like
sparkling drinks chocolate I love
chocolate
I like Ramen
yes the calm noodles so I brought it
like
66
16 office not 60 16 of it I love sweets
um
my pig my pig is ice cream
yeah I love it
I like massage yeah yes
very useful lots of medicine stuff and
also like
oil like essential oils and those like
massaging sticks and stuff I guess
sparkling water yeah
yeah yes
oh doesn't it export not yet not yet
okay
um from home from Korea I think Albert
come now yes
I recommend you that's your chip it's
very delicious
[Music]
honey
oh oh
so many but I love
white sneakers
so I have
a
sneakers maybe I have I have plenty of
sneakers because I like many
presents so but I the
really sneakers that I wore is like
three
three of them yes it's so hard the
kitchen is really hard
I don't know
20 but but I always
wearing the one sneakers like because we
always practice and
the coffee is really the best so yeah
recently oh I have
Maybe
nine nine nine nine
sneakers you're okay
19 19 sneakers I have I have 19. what's
up oh but but recently second one
yeah I only three sneakers all white I
have lots of shoes cut and lots of
sneakers especially because I like kind
of uh Gathering like colorful sneakers
but I don't I wear them all but not all
the time it depends on my mood of the
day I don't know how many but like I
have like
four three or four in a row
and probably like five and then there's
like five so and like yeah I can't do
the math right now so yeah
thank you
Colony I I love Colony so
Ariana Grande Ariana Grande I think
the mood could be different a lot but I
really I'm a really big fan of Ed
Sheeran so
if there's a chance I Really Wanna
and my knees
Beyonce yeah yeah
she have many
plenty of expensive and
um
foreign
right
[Laughter]
[Music]